[Musique]
souvent on reproche aux journalistes de
ne s'intéresser qu'à ce qui va mal mais
bon c'est un petit peu comme si vous
disiez un psy si vous lui reprochez
aussi qu'il ne s'intéresse qu'est ce qui
va mal chez son patient ce type normal
ça fait partie de la description poste
mais c'est vrai malgré tout que entre
les difficultés qu'on croise dans notre
vie et malheureusement elles sont
inévitables et malheureusement que ce
soit la souffrance la maladie des
difficultés professionnelles
personnelles les chagrins d'amour cdd
violence on endure conduire sur le
moment et puis ensuite comporte avec
soin et en plus de cette violence de la
vie en quelque sorte
eh bien il ya là la violence du monde et
s'il ne faut pas sonner stétié malgré
tout c'est je crois important de pouvoir
a digéré de voir la mettre à distance
pour avoir à dire justement là la bonne
distance chose ne pas être dans un dans
un excès de la souffrance ni dans une
sorte d'indifférence
alors le but de cette séance est ce
qu'elle va vous apporter concrètement
c'est de vous permettre de mettre à
distance les souvenirs douloureux de
votre passé parce que pourquoi ont duré
deux fois des choses une fois quand on
met vie et une fois quand on s'en
souvient donc autant les mettre à
distance
alors si vous voulez vous avez des
séances d'hypnose des mp3 vous pouvez
retrouver sur le site psy tirer quand je
pourrai faire
il ya également chaîne youtube
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner ça ça nous
encourage tout simplement et puis
surtout surtout vous avez le site du
figaro live
puisque nous sommes en train de
constituer de construire toute une
collection de séance d'hypnose pratique
le but c'est de considérer ce qui est
important dans nos vies et de travailler
à les améliorer au concret parce que
matt stover l'acno c'est ça n'a pas
vraiment de limite on peut travailler
sur tous les aspects de nos vies de nos
pensées c'est l'amener aux aspects du
quotidien je pense qu'il est important
si vous êtes prêts commencez à vous
installer confortablement à faire une
séance d'hypnose assez courte parce que
le travail sur le passé et
paradoxalement assez facile à faire
donc vous aurez une transe légère très
agréable comme d'habitude mais légères
elles s'approfondira de fois en fois
plus vous recommencerez cette séance et
puis ceux touchant et vous considérer ça
comme un travail pratique sur vous même
je vous invite à travailler sur un
maximum de souvenirs sur un maximum
d'informations que vous seriez croisés
et qui vous aurait perturbé comme ça le
travail sera de plus en plus efficaces
et puis au bout d'un moment ça va
devenir quelque chose assez instinctif
et vous ressentirez comme une sorte de
deux bonnes distances par rapport au
monde
d'abord à vous souvenir un camion alors
commencé à fixer un point peu importe
local regarder le avec un regard doux
peu importe ce que cela veut dire c'est
peut-être un avant-goût de la douceur
cette séance d'hypnose va installer en
vous et puis
tout simplement laissez vous porter si
vous portez par ma voix laissez vous
porter par son rythme sa douceur sa
lenteur parfois et les moments où votre
esprit décrochera sait très bien où des
phrases des mots disparaîtront des
moments où vous serez finalement plus
dans un état inconscient au conscience
là aussi sont très bien je vous invite à
les accepter
et comme toutes les séances que nous
sommes en train de construire avec le
figaro elles sont tournées on ice emerse
d'air avec des gros binauraux des micros
qui permet de retranscrire dans l'espace
le sauna trois dimensions donc je
pourrais parler tant toi votre règle au
jeu tantôt à votre et droite et bien sûr
pour profiter de ce sont
particulièrement immersif
il est préférable d'utiliser des
écouteurs tout simplement alors moment
que l'on pense et s'accroche cet écran
pendant que les sons se font se défont
donc les pensées se forment se déforme
d'autres formes 5 peu importe le moment
où les us fermeront si vous connaissez
déjà me voir si vous connaissez déjà
cette séance certainement très vite
peut-être même maintenant qui s'est plus
tard bob vous entendez ma voix celle ci
va se préciser de plus en plus en vous
parlons tantôt à votre conscience
tantôt à votre inconscient à leur gauche
à l'oreille droite vous permettre un peu
dans cette alternance de perdre quelques
instants pied pour vous retrouver en
sécurité dans la stabilité et le calme
de la transe
et simplement parce que vous êtes bien
posée parce que pour une fois tout est
pris en charge
s'occupe de vous n'est pas d'efforts à
faire c'est à moi de vous accompagner
vers libye lance alors dans ce repos
dans cet avant goût de ce repos le corps
se dirige vers la transe et ça passe par
des choses aussi simples que vous pouvez
observer c'est la respiration qui est
plus lente
le régulière un peu comme le flux et le
reflux d'une vague et puis aussi les
sensations du corps plus précise quelle
qu'elle soit c'est le regard un peu plus
lourd bien sûr de paupières aussi un peu
plus longue mais aussi le poids des bras
des gens un engourdissement peut-être
comme des prémices d'une sensation ce
temps juste avant le sommeil qu'on
appelle les tailles la logique un prêt
endormissement donc en tout cas le
soupçon le début 'l'indice des indices
qui montrent que de plus en plus vous
entrez aux entrées entre en calmant
prenez deux respirations profondes comme
pour passer totalement à quelque chose
d'autre
comme pour
[Musique]
construire un rempart face au monde
extérieur comme pour vous retrouver dans
votre citadelle intérieur c'est bien
comme ça alors que dépenser croche se
décrochent la croche se décrochent votre
respiration devient plus profond le
gagnent ils vous pouvez sentir cet air
calme et frais que vous inspirez sentir
de quelle manière il se diffuse dans les
poumons comme des racines de cas et
sentir comment progressivement où le
corps se détend
de plus en plus qu'à
plus en plus détendu c'est très bien
comme ça
il ya cette respiration de plus en plus
profondes
il y a cette arcade le vrai que vous
inspirer ses racines de cannes dans les
poumons il y à tout le corps qui se
détend toujours de plus en plus de plus
en plus avant vers la transfère le cas
de plus en plus en transe cadres et les
autres sensations s'installe sans même
qu'il soit obligatoire de les remarquer
c'est la respiration plus lourde
ce sont les bras qui sont aussi un peu
plus l'eau les gens le plus long encore
loin comme si l'énergie conscient de la
volonté acceptait pour un temps de
partir vous qu'il repose tout à fait
donc les bras soit plus lourd que les
gens ne soient plus lourd que vous soyez
plus lourdes montre de plus amples cas
et qu'est-ce que d'hypnose sinon un
sommet un seul mail ou un sommeil
profond un sommeil récupérateur
qu'est ce que c'est que l'hypnose sinon
monde à l'intérieur de soi que l'on
ignore son sais c'est que l'infini grâce
à l'hypnose justement à redécouvrir à
redévelopper le calme profond soit et le
corps qu'amcor calmement posé sur un
fauteuil canapé un lit celui solidement
ancré sur le sol sol solidement créé sur
les fondations de cet immeuble de cette
maison ses fondations créées cela vit la
ville ancrée
mon voyage plus loin comme vous et j'ai
de plus en plus loin vous même la terre
ce film ancré dans le système solaire le
système solaire selon credo le galaxy et
galaxy ancrée dans l'univers l'univers
ancré dans le temps et vous qui vous ont
créé de plus en plus en france 3 qu'il
est tout ce temps ce temps du sommeil
quand dans les rêves enfin on échappe un
autre condition humaine on est chez nous
souvenir
on échappe même à notre propre
personnalité pour devenir sous toutes
ses formes ce que le rêve proposez vous
pouvez devenir un animal vous de venir
juste l'observateur d'une autre vie et
vous avez cette sensation agréable
tantôt d'apporter par quelque chose
d'extérieur sont que la volonté besoin
de données mouvement aux gestes au corps
vous êtes transporté par le raid
transporter de plus en plus en transe et
dans ce rêve où tous les possibles sont
là où tout peut advenir
c'est là que se trouve certainement la
possibilité de ressourcement de prise de
distance par rapport au temps chaque
soir quand on dort tout cela est trié
intégré et dans la pluralité des mondes
que l'on croise dans l'hypnose des rêves
alors alors on devient audrey en
devenant autres c'est le passé qui
devient dépassé sur le passé qui prend
de plus en plus de champ qui disparaît
dans le néant du sommet il disparaît
dans le néant du sommeil le passé
dépassé les informations n'ont pas
oublié mes mises de côté pour que le
présent nuit puisse fleurir de plus en
plus vous entrez de plus en plus en
france 2 alors que vous pensez
s'accroche se décrochent s'accroche et
se décroche alors que faire faisons ce
faire elle trouve rien d'autre que ce
que l'on s'est fait avant même que vous
savez déjà plus que vous le saviez que
vous aviez un les yeux fermés dans une
transe agréable c'est très bien de votre
respiration la voix tout cela va vous
faire entrer dans une transe de plus en
plus agréable et je vais apprendre à
votre inconscient trois manières de
mettre à distance le passé trois
manières pour pouvoir vous sentir plus
libre plus léger à mesure que vous
entrez en entrant cette capacité de
calme qui se développe et c'est pour ça
qu'il est aussi important de travailler
chaque jour sur l'hypnose peut-être sur
d'autres techniques de relaxation
simplement pour pouvoir développer en
vous cette capacité à simplement être
bien vous apprenez à être bien
suffisante et à votre esprit inconscient
de vous faire vivre un cinéma un très
beau cinéma d'être un cinéma comme il
n'en existe plus ou un cinéma que vous
aimez ou tout simplement votre cinéma
vous savez vous le savez depuis votre
enfance il ya quelque chose de magique
dans le cinéma vie d'autres vies
brossant d'autres émotions au voyage
cinéma profondément initiatique
on en sort changer mon sort heureux non
sort bien souvent plus humain et le
cinéma cet art de mettre la bonne
distance des choses pour vous permettre
d'apprécier la vie plutôt que d'en
souffrir
alors maintenant que ce cinéma se
précise en vous cédez pouvoir installer
votre corps sur un fauteuil confortable
de ce cinéma est plutôt que de devoir
d'observer directement même s'ils sont
déjà mises à distance sur cet écran
d'information des souvenirs douloureux
vous allez pouvoir t'évoque record et
vous installer dans cette pièce elle
aussi un peu magique qu'est celle du
projecteur de cet endroit d'où dans un
rayon de lumière sorte les images de
l'imagination même la source de toute la
magie du cinéma
pendant que vous êtes accompagné par ma
voix dans cette cabine loin de l'écran
toutes les difficultés passées du cross
ont défilé sur cet écran ça va créer
double dissociation et cela va se
dérouler encore pendant une petite
minute
très bien pendant qu'en vous ce prêt si
ce travail intérieur toujours protégé
dans le calme de ma voix car cet
éloignement
ce double éloignement et de l'écran et
de votre cas bien loin dans la sécurité
des souvenirs de l'enfance
cette madeleine de proust qui est pour
tout le monde le cinéma et maintenant
les difficultés ont vu se dérouler sur
l'écran de souvenirs ces informations
c'est le pouvoir en douceur rien corpore
votre corps donc bien sûr et observer
comme il est déjà plus calmes plus
légers comme s'ils avaient lâché du lest
les souvenirs des images trop lourde
règne
et vous pouvez retrouver notre corps
calme tranquille délester déjà d'une
partie de ses souvenirs toujours
présentes on vous met désormais beaucoup
plus légères sereine je vais apprendre à
votre esprit inconscient une deuxième
manière de mettre à distance
d'information les souvenirs le passé
votre inconscient on va vous faire vivre
un écran de télévision ou encore une
fois un écran de cinéma n'a aucune
espèce d'importance et sur cet écran ont
passé les images et ceux ci les son
souvenir pénible
ils méritent de disparaître tout
simplement et votre inconscient on va
faire en sorte que l'écran emprunte de
plus en plus de distance qu'ils
deviennent de plus en plus petit et
disparaissent comme ça innus kull
holloway vie consciemment ou
inconsciemment vous allez le faire
revenir
votre inconscient plus tôt et la
jeunesse à votre imagination
le choix des armes d'être fait qu une
massue peut-être avec une scie grand
port peut-être
un marteau c'est lé pouvoir casser cette
image la réduire en miettes les sentiers
ce faisant que vous reprenez le contrôle
de vos sensations sentir que quelque
chose peut-être de la colère de la peur
de la tristesse que cette chose
disparaît dans la joie de pouvoir casser
ce mauvais souvenir
et maintenant
celui ci est en miettes sur le sol et
ici le feu tout simplement le très bien
ce qu'est ce que tout disparaisse
transformer en cendres emportée par le
vent jusqu'à ce que tout disparaisse
c'est parfait essais techniques comme la
précédente
vous pouvez aussi l'utiliser
consciemment quand vous en aurez besoin
vous pourrez aussi par exemple utiliser
cette technique non pratiquants d'aïkido
lorsque des souvenirs douloureux au
travers imaginez que vous l'étranger en
deux grâce au sabbat technique mental
très très simple et parfaitement
efficace en revanche ce qui est
important c'est de travailler ce maximum
de souvenirs
non je vais demander à votre esprit
inconscient d'où va vivre une image très
positive très agréable confiant je tape
bien accompagner dans un endroit en tout
cas où santé particulièrement bien et
images les sons les sensations se
préciser
je vous ai des pouvoirs
tout simple en une photographie mentale
de cette image positive
c'est très bien comme ça
maintenant je vais inviter votre esprit
inconscient replacer à nouveau sur un
écran 10 temps ce qui reste que soit
quelques images ou un film qui se déroba
mort nous observera déjà comme cela vous
touche - comme les plus difficiles y
penser et puis en incrustation bas à
gauche vous allez mettre votre
inconscient va mal l'image positive la
photographie mentale et souche un coup
celle-ci va remplacer recouvrir d'un
coup images les images des gatti notre
inconscient on recommence l'image
négative sur l'écran l'incrustation au
pâtis image positive souich image
positive recouvre tout et pendant 15
secondes
votre esprit inconscient par faire cela
c'est comme ça que ses difficultés ses
souvenirs se désactiver neutraliser
image positive puisque ce processus
devient de plus en plus rapide
super
maintenant
vous pouvez si vous le souhaitez compter
intermondes un simple pour sortir de 30
ans aussi laisser votre inconscient
travailler sur d'autres souvenirs
d'autres images du passé des
informations
il y aura d'abord cette double
dissociation cette double distance prise
dans le cinéma puis cette mise à
distance sur un écran écran qui
disparaît les grands l'on brise comme si
en quelque sorte ont changé la manière
dont l'image est encodé en bout et puis
ensuite cette alternance entre les rast
désormais inactifs ayant perdu la
nocivité et cette alternance donc entre
ces restes de souvenirs et l'image
positive qui s'imposera de plus en plus
les clients alternant avec ces images
négatives finira de nettoyer
complètement votre esprit de la lourdeur
de toutes ces choses je vous accompagne
désormais en silence et laisse à votre
inconscient soit possibilités et donc de
continuer son travail avec le même ordre
la même efficacité
hier de retourner maintenant au temps
présent simplement content de reims